Graduates of the Class of 2021,
family members, and friends,
it is a privilege to
speak with you as
part of this
remarkable moment.
You are probably feeling many
emotions right now.
I often tell graduates that
commencement is a field day for
me as a psychologist, and that
has never been more true.
For over a year, we
have walked a strange and
historic path together.
We are now at the end of an
academic year like no other.
Although our traditions may
look different this year,
they are just as
meaningful as ever.
Commencement is a
time of celebration.
It is a chance for you,
our graduates, to revel
in your accomplishments.
It is also an opportunity to
reflect and say thank you.
So many people have been part
of your journey to this moment.
I hope you will find time to
tell them how much they have
meant to you.
I also would like to
say thank you, to you.
Graduates of Yale College,
you have made history at Yale.
Many of you have studied, and
learned, and made a community
here under
extraordinary conditions.
Others have studied remotely
from around the world.
Day after day, for more
than a year.
You have made sacrifices for
the greater good, helping keep
our neighbors on campus
and in New Haven safe.
It has not been easy.
Your "bright college years"
have not always been
what you expected.
Like people around the world,
you have experienced loss,
grief, and uncertainty.
And yet,
you have repaid our communities'
trust and confidence in you
many times over.
Today, as we look to
the future, I would like to
share a personal story about my
past and my present.
I share it because I
hope it will shed some light
on your future.
It is a story about teachers
and the gifts they give us.
In the early 1970s,
I was a student at
Williamsville
High School North
outside of Buffalo, New York.
It was a pretty typical large
public high school.
We had a popular football team
and a marching band that
played at the games.
Perhaps it will surprise you to
learn that I did not play on
the football team, but I did
march with the band.
Now, you might wonder how I fit
into a school like this.
I actually earned
a varsity letter
for the drama club.
I was part of another student
organization as well,
a poetry club hosted by
two beloved English teachers,
Mr. and Mrs. Blaisdell.
A group of us would gather in
their home and share poems we
had written or come across.
We drank coffee, we talked
about poetry, it was all very
grown up, especially for kids
like us from Buffalo.
Our teachers were only in
their 20s, perhaps early 30s,
but they were sophisticated
adults and therefore seemed
much older to us. They cared
deeply about literature,
writing, and poetry.
And most of all, they cared
about us, their students.
In fact, I'm not the only
student of the Blaisdells
on the faculty here at Yale:
they taught English to
Chemistry Professor
Scott Miller
about a decade after me.
Fast forward forty-six years.
The kids from that poetry club
now have families and careers
of their own.
We have stayed in touch,
but usually we only see each
other every few years at best.
As a way of coping
with the social isolation of
the pandemic, we started
meeting over Zoom.
We shared poems, we drank
coffee together again.
Our former English teachers
from Williamsville North,
now retired, joined us.
And we found in the midst of so
much grief and loneliness,
a way to connect.
What does this mean for you,
the graduates of 2021?
First, my hope for each of you
is that you have made a friend
here at Yale, perhaps
a few friends
who will be there for you
in fourty-six years.
That is no small thing.
Second, I hope you have found
great teachers and developed
interests that you will take
with you for the rest
of your lives.
I don't mean only
your professional interests,
many of you, without question,
have found important mentors
who will continue to advise and
guide you, but you have also
found interests at Yale that
have nothing to do
with your careers.
For me, it was poetry,
theater, and music.
But for you, it may have been
an economics class or a
history seminar that made you
re-examine the world.
It might have been a certain
psychology class that helped
you think about happiness
in new ways.
Or maybe you heard a lecture or
attended an event that sparked
an interest in the
outdoors, or food, or dance.
These moments of inspiration
and learning
can happen anywhere.
We now know that they
can even happen on Zoom.
My friends from
Williamsville North
have gone into music, science,
medicine, law, and theater.
I'm a psychology professor
and university leader.
My point is, none of us are
professional poets,
and yet our experiences in the
poetry club were transformative.
From wonderful teachers,
I learned how to ask
different questions,
bigger questions.
In high school, I was always
trying to figure out what a
poem was "about".
I wanted to unlock
the secret meaning.
But Mr. Blaisdell would tell me,
"Peter, what the poem is about
is not always
the most interesting question."
He encouraged me to appreciate
beauty and occasionally
put aside analysis.
He pushed me to use different
parts of my mind
and my emotions.
Beyond poetry, my teachers
inspired in me and my friends,
a deep and joyful
love of learning.
They introduced us to interests
that made our lives richer
and more rewarding.
I recently had the privilege of
interviewing the poet
Louise Glück, who won the
2020 Nobel Prize for Literature.
Professor Glück has taught at
Yale since 2004.
She told me she thinks of
teaching as a way of
repaying her debts.
"You can't thank your teachers,"
she said, "except by performing
as they did for
another generation."
Soon you will leave Yale and
contribute to every field
and profession, as generations
of alumni have before you.
You will leave here
with gifts from your teachers,
from Yale professors,
and from others
throughout your lives.
And as Professor Glück says,
you can repay your teachers
by helping others
discover the world.
Over the past year, we have
learned so much about
ourselves and about what we
are capable of.
And we have been reminded again
and again that we
must keep learning.
There will always be new
challenges to tackle,
unexpected problems to solve.
We will have
to pivot and adapt.
And if we love learning, if we
are curious about the world and
the people in it, then that
task will be so much easier
and more fulfilling.
What will you do with
the gifts you have been given?
What gifts will you
give to the world?
I think of Emi Mahmoud,
a 2016 graduate of Yale College,
born in Darfur, Sudan, Emi
won the
International World
Poetry Slam Championship,
was honored by the BBC,
and met with President Obama,
all while still
a student at Yale.
Emi's poems often
deal with her experiences of
war and displacement.
Today, as the United Nations
goodwill ambassador,
she advocates for peace and
human rights,
particularly the
rights of children.
She is sharing her gifts
with the world
in a very powerful way.
In the book
Tuesdays with Morrie,
The sportswriter Mitch Albom
describes reconnecting with his
former professor,
Morrie Schwartz.
The elderly Morrie
is suffering with ALS,
Lou Gehrig's disease.
The book is an extended
reflection on life and death,
but it is also about the
relationship between a student
and his teacher.
At the end, Albom says,
"Have you ever really
had a teacher?
One who saw you as a
raw but precious thing,
a jewel that, with wisdom,
could be polished
to a proud shine?
If you are lucky enough to find
your way to such teachers,
you will always find
your way back."
I hope you find your way back.
Back to your teachers and
back to Yale.
I hope you will return to campus
and walk down Chapel Street
and enjoy the sunshine,
or the snow,
on Old Campus or Science Hill.
And I hope you will find ways
of sharing the joy of
discovery with others.
I hope you will share your
curiosity with a world that
needs questions as much as
answers,
that needs "light and
truth" more than ever.
I usually conclude my addresses
on commencement weekend with a
few words of verse. Over
the years, I have read from
Rabindranath Tagore,
Elizabeth Alexander,
Billy Collins, Marie Borroff,
and Claudia Rankine.
But most often I have turned
to the words of John Milton
from Paradise Lost.
You know those verses about
leaving the Garden of Eden
"with wandering steps and slow"
making one's way into a world
that is "all before" you?
There are moments when those
lines move me to tears.
In this challenging year,
though, paradise does not seem
the right metaphor for
our beloved campus.
But I look ahead with
great optimism,
and I trust you do too.
So perhaps these words of
Emily Dickinson
seem more appropriate at
this moment.
"Hope is the
thing with feathers
That perches in the soul
And sings the tune
without the words
And never stops,
at all"
Graduates of the
Class of 2021,
You are ready to
face the future with
optimism and determination.
You are ready to repay the
gifts your teachers have given
you and share the joy of
discovery with others.
You go with our best wishes
and our admiration.
Congratulations, and good luck!